how do you craft the hero's journey wow
that's super interesting Carson right
there hmm I think it starts with how you
define what a hero is even I think that
people think a hero is just somebody who
puts on the suit and a cape you know
what I mean and it can be there was a
concept I started working on a few years
ago where it was about a homeless man
who like it was a fad and you know lived
in the slums and he had met this this
girl she was like a foster Caden you
know she gotten my kidnapped they were
gonna traffic her or something like that
and you had this homeless man who nobody
just paid attention to and he she was
the only person who referred to him she
would see him every day and talk to him
and give him sandwiches and you know she
was the only friend he had you know and
he like went through all this stuff and
fought and died at the end to get this
little girl back you know I mean and and
she was but she was a kid no one cared
about you know and to me he's a hero you
know I mean like it's so I think
sometimes the the focus or the
perception of a hero is what we see in
all these superhero films but I feel
like and in really everyday situations
in any situation you can find a person
you would consider a heroic or a hero
and those stories need to be told as
well so I think that especially as
filmmakers like I don't want anyone to
get discouraged like as far as if they
feel like they can't make
a film like Superman or this big sort of
superhero film you can still make films
about heroes you know like and everyday
walks of life like it doesn't have to be
just just status quo example of what a
hero is it can be any scenario any
situation like a dog can be a hero you
know yeah I think there's so many ways
to approach that idea and I always but I
always try to go with what we may not
have seen before like I always try to
find something they always say like
there's no original story you know that
sort of thing but I think the approach
can be original or the way that you
attack the material can be an original
way you know I don't know if that
answered the question but I just you
know
you